[Musik]
leckeres pesto besteht eigentlich aus
frischem basilikum parmesan und
pinienkernen bei den teuren zutaten kann
das so schmecken
sebastian zeigt mit welchen tricks die
industrie trotzdem passte für unter
einem euro ins regal stellen kann
pesto genovese ein klassiker aus der
italienischen küche aber auch bei uns in
deutschland sehr beliebt nur mit
feinsten zutaten frischem basilikum
kaltgepresstes olivenöl parmesan käse
ein jahr lang gereift pinienkerne
bisschen knoblauch fertig die
herstellung ist so leicht einfach alles
in den mixer werfen und ein paar
sekunden später ist ein original pesto
alla genovese fertig zum genuss
[Musik]
lecker aber es auch keine kunst bei den
teuren zutaten kann das nur schmecken
fast drei euro kosten allein die zutaten
für legis testo im supermarkt gibt es
testo für 99 cent
ich war heute mal eine rezept
optimierung zum viertel der kosten aber
mit hundertprozentigem geschmack der
klappt ein hauch von basilikum für den
rest petersilie
die ist genau so grün wie basilikum im
einkauf aber billiger im ersten
produktionsschritt geht es nicht um
geschmacks sondern allein um optik und
konsistenz jetzt brauchen wir noch ein
bisschen geschmack damit wir nicht ganz
so viel teureren käse einsetzen müssen
natürlich verwende ich kein parmesan
sondern irgendeinen hartkäse stabile
sich das ganze mit kartoffel fahrer
sagen teure zutaten durch billige
ersetzen
dieses prinzip hat die
lebensmittelindustrie zur perfektion
getrieben
in fertig pesto stecken keine teuren
pinienkerne sondern günstige cashewnüsse
das rösten sorgt dafür dass die nüsse
ihren natürlichen geschmack verdoppeln
also wird richtig schön intensiv
doppelter geschmack heißt halb soviel
nüsse fertig und ich würde sagen eine
handvoll reich oder
cashew nüsse statt pinienkernen pflanzen
statt olivenöl bis jetzt hat sebastian
keine einzige original zutat verwendet
nicht sehr neutral
wir wollen aber den geruch von italien
in dieses kleine gefäße zaubern paar
tropfen basilikum europa können doch
helfen aromen kommen in der industrie
vor allem deshalb zum einsatz weil die
eingesetzten zutaten nicht den richtigen
geschmack haben
[Musik]
basilikum satte italiener aber nix da
peter sie durch seine rezept optimierung
hat sebastian lege den wert der zutaten
von knapp 3 euro auf unter einen euro
gedrückt
bei einer blindverkostung will er
beweisen dass sich verbraucher schon
längst an industrieprodukte gewöhnt
haben schlägt billig pesto wirklich das
original aus besten zutaten hallo sie
sind die bürger und ich bin der hartmut
hallo walburga hallo ich bin der
sebastian lust auf ein paar nudeln okay
es gibt desto sehr gut aus ja auch
richtung gut finde ich auch gut
etwas ist nur noch schmeckt bitte schön
sagt lob nach gewinn hier bei uns wird
gegessen was auf den tisch kommt
rein optisch ist zwischen den beiden
gerichten kein unterschied zu erkennen
[Musik]
düsseldorfer sebastian lege trotzdem auf
die schliche kommen immerhin hat der
produktentwickler bei seiner rezeptur
einfach alles weggelassen was ein pesto
gut und teuer macht es schmeckt beides
aber das hier schmeckt mir ein bisschen
besser
also ich bin der meinung dass die erste
portion intensiver schmeckt es weiter
sebastian läge es billig pesto führt
tatsächlich fast alle tester hinters
licht
ich finde ersten bissiger und kräftiger
der zweite ist auch recht witzig aber
ich bin der erste da ist auch ein
bisschen vielleicht mehr käse oder es
kommt mir so vor
acht von zehn testesser mögen das
gestreckte billig pesto lieber als das
original
[Musik]
mal verraten wie sie über silikon da
drin steckt soviel basilikum drin
richtig so viel basilikum steckt da drin
[Musik]
und hier ehrlich jetzt nicht gedacht
dass wir mich jetzt so leicht drucken
kann die industrie dagegen weiß das ganz
genau ob parmesan oder pinienkerne
basilikum oder oliven will
wir finden kein einziges supermarkt
pesto das nach originalrezept
hergestellt ist alle enthalten die
typischen zutaten nur in extrem geringen
mengen
[Musik]
doch damit nicht genug
hinter dem rücken der verbraucher
verändern viele hersteller im laufe der
jahre ihre rezepturen immer weiter fast
immer tauschen sie typische hochwertige
zutaten gegen billigere aus so enthält
das schoko müsli von köln heute nur noch
sieben prozent schokolade und damit 30
prozent weniger als noch im jahr 2008
[Musik]
im krüger cappuccino ist der anteil
echten cafés im gleichen zeitraum um 20
prozent gefallen
auf nur noch 42 gramm pro dose
und auch der nuss gehalt von
müsliriegeln ist in den vergangenen
jahren um 20 prozent zurückgegangen der
nuss regel enthält jetzt nur noch fünf
prozent
[Musik]
in einigen fällen begründen die
hersteller das mit rohstoffknappheit
gerade bei den müssen zb wir haben wir
in den letzten jahren eher schlechte
ernten gehabt weltweit aber das
rechtfertigt natürlich nicht das produkt
genau so erscheinen zu lassen und dann
hochwertige zutaten einfach raus zu
nehmen und zum gleichen preis weiter zu
verkaufen
rotes oder grünes pastor was mit ihr
liebe und macht ihr eure selbst sagt es
uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mit bei essen wissen
wollt dann abonniert die zdf besser
esser und schaut in den nächsten zwei
clips